made a protest in support of women's
right and workers rights turned violent
in cities around the world demonstrators
in Paris threw Molotov cocktails at
police four officers were hurt and in
the Pacific Northwest dozens of people
were arrested yesterday during clashes
with police John Blackstone shows us how
a rally in Oregon's largest city turned
chaotic police had to resort the so
called flashbangs to try to break up an
unruly crowd in Portland Oregon Monday
the city was forced to shut down its May
Day march after the peaceful protest to
support labor and immigration rights
turned violent anarchists clashed with
officer trashing police vehicles and
some businesses in the Washington state
capitol of Olympia police say dozens of
people dressed in black hurled rocks and
marbles there were several arrests this
is a group here that was very focused as
a group to really engage us and try to
frankly assault officers the protests
were just some of the many
demonstrations that took place across
the country from Los Angeles to Chicago
and New York
in perhaps a not-so-subtle nod to that
now-infamous Pepsi commercial some
demonstrators offered police a can of
Pepsi which in some cases wasn't so well
received
for the most part demonstrators came
together peacefully hoping to keep
attention on their primary cause I'm
here to fight for rights for rights for
workers rights for immigrants rights for
everybody everybody works for working
cause we need to be heard for CBS this
morning John Blackstone San Francisco